Croatia has become the 20th country to join the Eurozone...
...as it adopted the Euro as its currency.
BBC's Emily Brown explains why.
A new year, a new currency.
Croatia says goodbye to its Kuna currency as it adopts the Euro.
This is the moment the country's Finance Minister...
…pulls out the first Euro bill from a cash machine.
And Croatia will become the 20th member of the Eurozone...
…after nearly a decade since it joined the EU.
The nation of four million people joins the Schengen Zone...
…which allows people to move freely around its member nations.
But Croatians have mixed feelings about the change.
It's always great for me to have Kuna when I came to Croatia,...
…but the Euro is easier.
It's easier when you're in Europe.
We can be emotionally attached to the Kuna because of history...
…but one has to live realistically.
It's always better to be with someone who is strong,...
…who is something, than to be on the sidelines.
I love Kuna and as you can hear, we will have as much as our pension allows.
Meanwhile, experts say adopting the Euro will help protect Croatia's economy...
...at a time when inflation has been soaring globally,...
…since Russia's invasion of Ukraine.
And it's hoped its entry into a borderless area...
…will provide a boost to the tourism industry.
It's an important milestone in the history of Croatia, the Euro, and the EU as a whole.
Emily Brown, BBC News.